there will be something missing from the
leo christmas market in the coming days
many of the british tourists the traders
usually enjoy seeing france's decision
to halt non-essential travel from the uk
will mean lost profits not just at the
stalls but from the hotels and
restaurants in the city a lucky few did
make it into france before the new curbs
come in there was huge relief in the leo
yura style station
i have terminal cancer so this is my
last holiday abroad so i've got months
we've come for the weekend to go to
disneyland i was really relieved that i
was able to get here in time and not be
told that i can't come here anymore so i
can see my sister who lives and works
here
but plenty of would-be tourists have
been left devastated including the
kohl's family who should have been
hitting the ski slopes of france this
weekend
had to tell the kids they won't be going
um we're frantically ringing around
trying to
claw back what money we can
not just in terms of
what the trip has cost us but also covid
tests transfers
skiing lessons all of those things that
we've booked that have come at great
cost christmas plans for thousands are
likely to be affected as come saturday
people who are not french residents or
citizens will have to have a compelling
reason to travel from the uk but the
french government insists the measures
are necessary because of high rates of
the omicron variant in the uk
tourism
will restrict the entry of tourists and
business people without french or eu
nationality people coming to france from
the uk will have to isolate themselves
in a location of their choice for seven
days there won't just be emotional and
financial pain for disappointed tourists
but for ferry companies and airlines as
trips are cancelled at what should be
one of the busiest periods of the year
the travel ban has affected us by
effectively wiping out our christmas
season we have around 22 000 passengers
who are booked with revenue of roughly 2
million that um that we will lose
france is taking a hard line against
non-essential travel from the uk
tourists hoping to spend some of
christmas here are being told to stay
away and the big question now is whether
other eu nations will follow suit
dashing the holiday plans of many
the festive period may not prove quite
as merry as many from the uk had hoped
michelle clifford sky news leo